معنى من عمان اللواء فايز الدولي الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي سياده اللواء 11
شهرا على هذه الحرب في اي اطار تندرج عوده
خيرسون الى الواجهه
يعني اولا عوده خرسون هي لم تخرج يعني تم
استعاده السيطره على الاجزاء التي تقع الى
الشمال من نهر
كان التوقع ان تقوم القوات الروسيه بعبور
النهر ولكن يبدو ان هناك معضلات عده بناء
الخطه الدفوع المنظومه الدفاعيه الروسيه
وصعوبه تنفيذ عمليه عبور يضاف الى ذلك
تركيز الهجمات
الروسيه في اقليم دومباس
فيسك واشتداد القتال تحديدا حول باخمود
فتم اعاده صياغه الاولويات وبالتالي تم
نقل جزء من القوات التي كانت مخصصه لخوض
معركه خرسون تم نقلها قسم الى زمولوجيا
وقسم اخر لتعزيز القوات المقاتله في
دونيسك وبعض المناطق الاخرى اذن يقول
خرسون لا تزال داخل برواز الصوره القتاليه
ولم تخرج
الحديث ايضا
اولا يعني ودا اسالك ما حاجه روسيا الى ان
تكون الاراضي البيلاروسيه جزءا من هذه
الحرب
يعني هذا في البدايه كان من اجل تشتيت
الجهد
وافشال الخطه الدفاعيه الاوكرانيه لكن بعد
الفشل الذي حدث في كيب واجبرت القوات
الروسيه على الانتفاء والانسحاب والاكتفاء
بمحاوله السيطره على الاقاليم الاربعه
التي تقع الى الشرق والجنوب من نهر همم لم
يعد هناك حديث في الفتره الاخيره همم تم
همم كثره الحديث وتناولت الاخبار ولكن
هناك او همم مؤشرات يعني الجانب الروسي في
الجانب الاوكراني همم يؤكد ولكن يقلل من
الاحتماليه انما المؤشرات التي يمكن
اعتمادها تبقى هذا الخيار ضمن دائره
المنطقه الرمادي ما هي المعوقات المعوقات
استدعاء استنادا الى وكالات الاستخباراتيه
الغربيه سواء ولا الشيعه اي اي او وزاره
الدفاع البريطاني كلاهما اشار الى تراجع
حده القتال بسبب نقص الذخائر والصواريخ
وبالتالي عدم قدره الجيش الروسي على شن
عمليات ودخول فصل الشتاء اما ما هي
المؤشرات الداعمه يتم الارتكاز والاجتناد
الى خطاب الرئيس بوتين في غرفه العمليات
او في قياده عمليات همم
المسؤول عن اداره عمليات المنطقه الخاصه
اول هذه المؤشرات استخدام الرئيس بوتن
كلمه حرب بدل من عمليه عسكريه خاصه
الاخرى انه اكد على زياده عدد الجيش
الروسي الى واحد ونص مليون اكد على ضروره
دمج الطائرات المسيره والذكاء الاصطناعي
في اداره المعركه اكد على ضرو اعراب فعل
سويت الثالوث الاستراتيجي وقام بتزويد
الوحدات المعنيه بصواريخ سيركن والسرمد
اكد على ضروره زياده فاعليه المنظومه
الاداريه مجمل هذه العوامل وغيرها يوحي
بان روسيا قد تشن عمليه ولكن السؤال متى
هل في فصل الشتاء كما حدث في المره
الماضيه ام تنتظر حتى بدايه الربيع انما
من من اللحظه التي يتحدث بها حتى ذلك
الوقت سيكون هناك متغيرات تنفي او تؤكد
شكرا جزيلا لك يا سياده اللواء فايز
الدويري متحدثين الينا من عمان